- Hello, everyone, thanks
for joining the session.
So today, we're gonna
talk a little bit about
one of the growing performance
challenges with AWS customers
and really the hybrid
cloud customers in general.
And that has to do with agentic AI
and AI applications in general,
which, although they're very powerful,
they tend to be unpredictable in usage
from a resource perspective.
So we're gonna spend a
bit of time talking about
how this problem kind of manifests,
a little bit more about
the problem itself,
and then as well discuss
some potential solutions,
because, ultimately, you wanna make sure
that you maintain the
performance of the end users
who are using the agentic AI,
but also make sure that you
are as efficient as possible
when it comes to the cost allocations,
so you can avoid that bloat.
So all right, let's get into it.
So before I get started,
would love to get some
feedback from the audience,
just a quick poll in
terms of where you are
with adoption of agentic AI.
Raise your hands if you're just exploring,
like you're just getting started
with learning about agentic AI
and where it might apply
for your environment.
Okay, make sense.
How many of you are
running proof of concepts
where you actually have some workloads
and it's in development
and you're seeing that?
Okay, great.
How many of you are in early production
where you actually have some real users
and a number of work
streams applied to that?
Great.
And then last, business critical
where like you've got real users,
you're using this at scale,
it's a big part of your
ROI, you're seeing that.
Anybody in that category?
Okay. Alright.
So not quite yet that at
that maturity adoption level,
but a lot of that kind of makes sense
given what we see from our customers, too.
Okay, so just expanding on
the hidden cost of agentic AI.
And a lot of times,
what you see is overprovisioning
and resource bloat.
And primarily, this comes down to
because people don't make
performance or resource decisions
based upon averages.
Usually, they'll take
the worst-case scenario,
because they're worried that
performance might suffer.
And what that leads to
is really conservative capacity decisions,
because ultimately they might be afraid
of this performance degradation,
which will lead them to
oversized GPU instances,
overallocate kind of RAM
farms, overprovision storage.
And this leads to a lot of idle costs
for these expensive resources.
And so what you'll see from a lot of teams
is that for fear of creating
these performance buffers,
they will overallocate
these expensive resources.
And then many times,
just because they're afraid of that peak
that might happen, right?
There are static scaling
policies which are in place,
but some of the problems
with these scaling policies
is they tend to be reactive.
And so if you have like
a peak that happens,
then it's already too late
for these scaling policies to take effect,
because like I said, with
agentic AI and AI apps,
a lot of times, the usage
is unpredictable, right?
And it also requires a fair
amount of human intervention
to stay on top of that.
So you are consistently looking
at those scaling policies
or taking remediation to deal with that.
All right, so talking a little bit about
how agentic AI is changing
how workloads behave.
A lot of this comes down to, you know,
with traditional legacy apps,
they typically follow
like a linear process:
a request comes in, it gets processed,
and it consumes resources.
And this typically follows
a straight line, right?
As more users show up and
hit the site for example,
then resources get consumed
in a linear fashion.
With agentic AI and AI apps,
it doesn't necessarily work that way.
It's very unpredictable.
It can plan, branch, and
then spawn many times,
like a lot of different
hundreds of microworkloads.
You could have gen AI talking
to another agentic AI,
talking to another agentic AI,
agentic AI talking to a number of APIs.
And all this is kind
happening in the background,
and it's creating these resource spikes
that can sometimes bring applications down
to its knees, right?
One user request for example can come in
and then create hundreds
of downstream tasks.
And this leads to
overprovisioning of GPUs.
You see issues with throttling and spiking
and as evidenced here,
like we've seen customers
who have to deal with overprovisioning
and sometimes utilization of 30%
of what they should be,
and 10 to 20 times the GPU
hours and really what's needed.
And ultimately, you
end up with a situation
of where these idle
resources just sit there
because they're afraid
of this performance risk
and then, ultimately,
become very wasteful,
and a hidden tax upon the organization.
So you really need to
consider how can I make sure
that my resource usage is dynamic
just as the agentic AI and AI
apps are dynamic themselves
based upon their nature.
All right, so talking about the gap
between insight and action
and just elaborating there.
You know, you do have
observability solutions,
which will do a great job
to give you information,
such as is there CPU throttling happening?
Is there GPU contention, or
are there latency spikes?
So you can see observation there,
but it doesn't necessarily do anything
for, okay, so when that happens,
like what do I actually do?
Maybe I can do an RCA, and
after the fact, go and fix that,
but it doesn't actually take actions
when you're dealing
with these types of
agentic AI applications.
On the FinOps side,
FinOps does a great job
in terms of, okay, well how
much am I spending here?
Or if I need to do reporting
for showback or chargeback,
I can see that and
allocate it appropriately
for these applications.
But again, it's primarily
around reporting.
It's not meant to do resizing of GPUs
or to handle these
dynamic scenarios, right?
It's really more about the cost allocation
versus actually like solving the problem.
So again, you have this problem
where even with some of
these other solutions,
in general, just oversizing
becomes the default.
Where many of our customers
who come to talk to us
about this problem will
essentially say, you know,
because I'm worried about performance
and maintain my SLOs,
I'll just oversize what I
have in the public cloud
or in even certain cases
in the private cloud.
And then again, back to static
scaling, this is in place,
but because of the nature of these apps,
they're so dynamic,
as I mentioned, in terms of
the way they do their work,
they can't keep up with the demand.
And so again, making sure
that you really look at the problem
from a resource perspective
and have dynamic resources
for the platforms resource that support it
to meet that ever-changing
demand is critically important.
We're gonna skip this
poll just based on timing.
So I'll move forward.
So in our particular case,
so what Turbonomic does
to deal with these problems
is we will deliver realtime optimization
to agentic AI workloads.
And what we will do is
we will provide actions
that look at the continuous
optimization by analyzing data
that comes from the GPU instances itself,
vCPU and vMem saturation,
throughput for storage and network
and look over time at these metrics
and then ultimately make
decisions across your environment
to rightsize based upon what
we see from these metrics.
So not only will we
analyze that information,
we'll look at the entire supply chain
from the agentic AI app,
but also look at the resources
that are supporting it
and real time scaled up and scaled down.
And we look across EC2,
the GPUs themselves, EKS,
and hybrid environments,
of course, AWS,
but also if you have
on-prem workloads as well
or in other public clouds.
And as we do this,
we make sure we maintain performance
and make sure we meet your SLOs
but also keep things efficient,
so cost is under control.
And as I mentioned, GPU optimization
is one of the most impactful
use cases that can help
with agentic AI,
given how much of the
resources come from there.
So as you see peaks come in
where more of the resources are needed,
we will rightsize them
and bring in additional
GPU instances, if required,
and leave them there.
But as demand goes down, in real time,
we'll rightsize those
instances and reduce them,
as well as other resources like memory
to reduce that overprovisioning
and deal with some of the challenges
that our customers face.
So by doing this on a continuous basis,
it takes a lot of the
human error out of it
and allows you to know
that these agentic AI apps
are going to run in a performant manner,
but also as efficiently as possible.
Alright, so I'm gonna take
you through an example.
This is a screenshot from our product,
and what we're looking at here
is a pending action,
which is essentially an
action that the user can take.
So this is an example
of, like, a manual action
and what Turbonomic has
been doing in this scenario
is it's been analyzing the
GPU usage, the GPU memory,
the instant sizing and
utilization in general.
And it's looking at this particular GPU,
which is a p3dn.24xlarge,
and which is one of the
more expensive GPUs for AWS.
And then it's essentially saying,
based upon the utilization
that we're seeing,
you can scale this down to a p3.8xlarge.
And we're able to do that
because we're looking
at the utilization data
and matching this up with the SLOs
and knowing that this is
going to be a safe action
that could be taken.
And as you can see just
from one single GPU,
you can get a savings of
$13,800 per month, right?
And this is still
keeping your performance,
maintaining the SLOs.
So just getting down to a
little bit of the details
because, you know, it's
a great recommendation
but our customers, our
operators want to know,
"Well, how do I know
that I can kind of trust
that that action is gonna
maintain performance?
So I need to see an
additional level of details."
So what you see here on the left hand side
and some of the charts are, okay, look,
starting with the GPU count
percentile and utilization,
what it's saying is that utilization
for this observation time
period is around 13%.
So hasn't really been used that much,
even though it's tied to
this EC2 instance, right?
And then you look at the
GPU memory utilization
and that's hovering around 22%.
Again, not really something
that is speaking to a
lot of usage in general,
and it's kind of hard
to see with the vCPU,
but I think that hovers around 3 to 4%.
So not a ton of of resources
are being used for this app.
So if you get into the resource impact,
the red box on the right,
you can see the current
and then post-recommendation
for this action.
And Turbonomic is recommending
to take the current GPU count
from eight to four
and predicting that this will lead
from 13 to 26% utilization.
That's a projection.
And then on the memory, it's
going from 32 to 16 gigabytes
and also predicting that the
utilization will go up to 44%
after taking its action.
Again, very safe,
you're not gonna see a
performance degradation
and then vCPU, it's around I think 13%
and then you see storage
throughput, network throughput,
in a similar situation.
So again, the nice thing here
is that, as an operator,
I can look at this action,
I feel good about it
because I know that the
performance is there
and we're still gonna maintain our SLOs,
and I feel comfortable doing that.
So it's not just like a,
"Hey, you're gonna save,
you know, the cost on this
action, you should just take it."
It's giving that user the confidence
that if I take this action,
and potentially even automate it,
I feel confident that
things will move forward
in a positive manner.
So I'll just wrap it up here
on this potential action.
So you can see kind of
overall the summary,
the on-demand rate goes
from $31.21 an hour
down to $12.
It does take it to account
ROI and savings plans.
And then you see the on-demand cost,
which again rolls up to around
$13,800 savings per month.
And this is just from
one single GPU instance.
So imagine if you have this
quite a big of investment,
then you're gonna see even more savings.
Alright, so let's talk a little bit
about some more of the details
in terms of how intelligent automation
can really transform your AWS environment.
Talked a lot about smart GPU optimization.
So what we will do is
automatically tune those GPUs.
We will rightsize, like I said,
based upon as demand
spikes up in real time.
And then we will bring
it down to make sure
we're as efficient from a cost perspective
as much as possible
so you can eliminate that idle capacity.
We also have real-time visibility.
So our application looks
at all of the resources
running in real time,
and we have a supply chain
that will map the business apps themselves
all the way down to the resources.
And we look across those resources
and how they work together
ranging from EC2 and EKS
and then the GPU environments
as I was mentioning,
a ton of different resources.
But we're able to correlate those metrics
and make sure that no harm is done
and that, ultimately, those applications
are getting the resources that they need.
And we'll also take into account,
there might be a potential issue
or a bottleneck in that supply chain,
and it may not be hitting
one specific resource,
but we'll identify that
and take account to be proactive
about what we're doing.
We also have orchestrator integration,
which will understand
things like pod placement,
affinity, resource quotas, and scheduling.
So we'll optimize the
container infrastructure
and the traditional
infrastructure layers together
for those business apps.
And we also have proactive
automation as well
so the previous example I gave
was like a single action,
but you can completely
automate the actions
that we're taking, so no human
intervention is required.
And like I said, if we are
identifying a potential issue,
we will go ahead and take care of it.
So you don't have to have those incidents
that happen that require like an RCA
and trying to problem-solve
after the fact.
Now at the end of the day, like I said,
part of what we do is around efficiency
and the cost savings and cost allocation
is a big part of that.
And we sell the businesses,
and so we will sum up individual actions,
we will sum up the overall ROI
of all of the automation that's happening
and present it back to our customers,
and that's available as well.
Want to go through a couple
case studies that apply directly
to some of this work that we've done.
And one of our internal customers
is the big AI models team,
or BAM, short for BAM,
which supports the LLM behind Watsonx.
And really what they were looking at
is they needed to
improve their environment
so that there was less
manual tuning required
to look after their environment.
And they have hundreds of containers
or running Kubernetes around
a hundred A100 NVIDIA GPUs.
And really what they wanted to do as well
was also, like, how
can we potentially make
these GPUs more dense
and get more ROI out
of what we were doing?
And so after using Turbonomic,
they saw some great results,
5.3 times in terms of idle GPU resources.
This took the headroom from 3 to 16.
So these 16 GPUs were...
These resources were
available for other workloads.
They saw two times throughput improvements
without impacting latency.
So that was a big benefit for them.
And again, they had 13
fewer GPUs that were needed,
and they were able to allocate these GPUs
to other workloads.
So huge savings for them
just by making the other
GPUs they had denser
and being able to allocate those new GPUs
as well as some of the
additional resources
from the GPUs they still had
allocated to other new AI workloads.
You can scan the QR code if
you want to hear more about it,
or read more about it.
But again, great example of
us working together on that.
Alright, so three things to remember today
I'd love to leave you with.
Agentic AI, again, because of its nature,
it's very unpredictable, right?
It requires a lot of resources,
it doesn't scale in a linear fashion.
So remember when you're
thinking about projects
along your maturity curve
of adopting agentic AI,
keep this in mind,
that you're gonna have
to be sensitive to this
because their bursts are
either unpredictable.
And visibility alone is not enough, right?
Just having access to
the resources behind it
and seeing some of the issues
can still create a lot
of manual work for you
to have to support it.
So being able to have a solution
that takes those insights
and creates continuous action
to rightsize your environment
and make sure those applications
have the resource that they
need is incredibly important.
You can really start with
one high-value workload.
So look at for a potential application
where you can still meet performance
but have GPUs be more efficient.
Look to target that and then scale it out
and see some of those results.
As far as working with us,
we'd love to work with you
in terms of let's look
at solution together,
identifying a pilot workload
and whether that's agentic
AI or a GPU service
where performance or cost matters most,
we can balance both of them.
We also have a broad set of integrations
across the hybrid cloud.
So we have a ton of AWS
services that we optimize.
We also do private cloud with
VMware and Nutanix and others,
OpenShift and hybrid
environments and other CSPs
that we support.
Also an opportunity to combine
observability and automation.
So our sister product, Instana,
provides even better metrics
to power our automation
and make our rightsizing
actions even better.
And I'll just leave you with
thank you for your time today.
I really appreciate all the feedback
and responding to the poll.
Our booth is over there
if you want to come
and get a demo and see us in action.
So please stop by.
And again, thank you for your time,
and have a great rest of the show.
(audience applauding)